Captain Marvel M Marvel and The
Marvelous Monica self-promotion anyone
together at last how could it go wrong
congratulations you have finally asked a
relevant question the mcu's latest
chapter has us marveling it's all the
wrong things last time I trusted someone
I lost an eye while Marvel Studios
panics over box office returns how about
we just make a good movie what made this
mash up such a misfire let us count the
ways and the warning if you're curious
we're spoiling everything ahead I can't
keep looking at it cuz it's horrible the
Marvel Studios logo used to really mean
something for audiences it was a sign of
quality or at least a sign that Robert
Downey Jr might show up and make some
naughty jokes let's face it this is not
the worst thing you've caught me doing
for the film industry that logo was a
warning sign it meant our movie is going
to open to at least $80 million so back
off this weekend is ours you best exotic
marold hotel we have a Hulk I feel as if
I'm on my deathbed even black Widow open
to $8 million and that came out when the
only person going to the movies was the
unkillable psycho Tom Cruz can't believe
I risk getting Co to go see black
widow but after Black Widow things
started to slip shangqi not as much
money eternals not as much money
Spider-Man Thor and black panther
sequels got things back on track a
little especially Spider-Man even though
that was mostly a gimmick I love you
guys outside of that success the box
office toour keep getting smaller you
mean shrinkage yes significant shrinkage
people stopped showing up if the choice
was see another Marvel movie or get a
second vasectomy we're going to
celebrate with the mother of all
cocktails the vasectomy audiences would
have chosen the latter I know I
did it's a trend that ended up in box
office disaster for what is definitely
not CED in Marvel 2 I guess the first
movie cracked the billion doll Mark
riding the wave of Avengers fever but in
the leadup to the Marvels the story was
about how low the opening weekend could
go pre-sales were as bad as the Flash
The Flash they didn't even put a baby in
a
microwave so the flash was bad enough
with a $55 million domestic opening
weekend but now here comes the Marvels
racing it to the bottom yeah and it's
not like a competition the box office
total for the movies opening weekend
came in at a grand total
of are we sure this isn't a DC movie
pretty devastating for the Marvels and a
disaster for the MCU one day you will
find something to make you feel this
shitty the MCU has put out more than 33
movies in the last 15 years for context
it took the James Bond franchise 60
years to produce 25 shut up it's 25
there a useful four-letter word and
you're full of it not all of those
projects are must sees hello Eternal s
love and thunder and just about every
Disney Plus show I don't care what you
say roie wasn't a scroll at Tony's
funeral but the Marvel's feels
especially skippable both for fans of
the franchise and especially the general
audience it's the marbles everybody you
know the team that doesn't even exist in
the comics it feels like no one asked
for this movie we just wanted X-Men in a
Fantastic Four but no here we have the
Marvels we made them up this franchise
has not been able to justify its own
existence despite putting out more
content than ever before it's just new
character after a new character standing
around waiting for something to happen
introducing and reintroducing the
Multiverse as a thing that exists oh and
here's K he got killed by ants in a
series that's lost its purpose the
Marvels feels inessential mosy being
marketed as a goofy fun Team Up movie
and clearly that's not enough anymore
fool me once shame on you it fool me We
Can't Get Fooled Again it also doesn't
help that critics from mosy mix on the
movie itself Lupa critic self-promotion
anyone Reuben Baron gave the film a
seven out of 10 but he couldn't help but
point out a lack of urgency or
consequence what do we learn Palmer I
don't know
sir I don't either he wrote it's
entertaining enough that you can't be
too bothered that it's barely about
anything and that it can't find the
focus to really commit to the things
it's almost about it's fine it's just
fine the bad reviews for the Marvels
called it things like the worst Marvel
movie yet a new low object Mis
I don't feel so good and even the
positive reviews use words like fine
generic and cluttered the two biggest
positives that every reviewer agrees on
are Iman Ban's performance and the brief
run time of just over 90 minutes that's
right the fact that it's short is one of
the best things about it that say
describe a good trip to aew your
driver's license you think that a
superhero movie starring an Academy
Award winner would do better with the
critics but then again I'm starting to
get hungry
you don't want to see me when I'm hungry
remember those dreams where you show up
to class only to realize you hadn't
studied for the final also you're in
your
underwear the Marvels is kind of like
that despite being a sequel to Captain
Marvel I guess two of the main
characters are from shows on Disney plus
one of which almost no one watched Khan
please come to my office ASAP you've
done something very wrong the villain of
the movie Dar Ben isn't exactly a Thanos
level threat she's not even diet Hela
she's more of a Kroger brand Ronin the
accuser minus anything we liked about
Ronin the accuser which is practically
nothing what are you doing her deal is
Revenge on Brie lson but what for fast X
it's happened off screen sometime after
the first movie and it's entangled with
the NeverEnding crease scroll drama
which also had its own show oh usually
only scratch the surface of mediocrity
you must be finally putting it all
together well done speaking of that Nick
Fury's here which first got got teased
all the way back in Spider-Man far from
home how many hours of content do you
need to watch to understand the plus of
this Captain Marvel sequel would you
believe us if we said you also need to
watch the second worst X-Men movie to
understand the end who's the furball
fact that you need to have seen so much
to only sort of understand it is a major
turnoff there's a possibility I don't
think so Quinn qu Marvel assumes that
audiences will watch just about
everything leading up to this movie but
now they're finding out that nobody
likes homework and all that
overconfidence is coming back to bite
them in the ass that is America's ass so
what's next for the MCU the real
question is who cares I don't care the
most exciting storyline in the franchise
right now is Jonathan major trial and
unfortunately She-Hulk probably won't be
showing up to save the day really okay
this was a mistake thankfully for Marvel
it seems they have a bit of time to
figure out what to do about Kang after
the the Marvels audiences will have the
likely Kang free Deadpool 3 and Captain
America Brave New World Captain
Deadpool no just just deadpol yeah once
phase five is done though there will be
no escaping the Kang canundrum we should
be dealing with a bigger problem here he
who remains I understand the next
Avengers movie is literally named after
him we couldn't be less excited so let's
stop wasting time Marvel Studios has two
major cards to play X-Men and Fantastic
4 after that it will be nothing but
sequels and spin-offs featuring
increasingly obscure characters
Darren surprised to see me some devoted
comic book fans would be delighted to
see Kevin feige announce a Beta Ray Bill
movie for 2029 but most people would
simply be wondering who this ugly guy is
and why he stole Thor's
armor but who knows maybe he'll show up
in secret Wars alongside Roger corman's
fantastic four and to L for rno's
Hulk what we do know for sure is that
Marvel Studios really wants people to
keep watching their movies and they're
now officially trying to remind you that
you used to really like them now this is
all about making myself credible in your
eyes again case in point the final
trailer for the Marvels which is a new
level of desperation it starts with
shots of characters that don't appear in
the movie never a good sign when Marvel
L to resort to clickbait it tries to
imply a Thanos connection but it's not
over
my work is inevitable and otherwise
tries to ride the Avengers wave just
like the first movie but this time it
didn't work oh my God we're a
team n thanks to the 2023 sagaa strike
which didn't let actors work on or
promote their projects the casts of the
Marvels weren't allowed to sell their
film that means no talk shows no hot
ones and no wired auto complete and no
Looper for a movie that tried to sell
itself on the chemistry of its three
leads the only one that could do an
interview was the damn cat you did a
great job the actor strike came to an
end on November 9th just one day before
the Marvels open for Thursday showings
the actors are now free to pay a visit
to Jimmy felon to Hype up their movie as
long as they can tolerate his never
ending
laughter superhero fatigue is real no
matter what Kevin feige says or how much
he wants to compare Marvel films to
classic novels but don't forget Kevin
most people prefer books that are good
good reboot Twilight that'll be more fun
than this at this point anyway a month
after fige said that Superhero fatigue
is fake Quantum Mania came out to series
worst reviews I didn't know he could do
that the visuals the writing the heroes
the villain everything was underwhelming
people have just gotten tired of these
middling low effort stories and the
Marvels didn't look like the one that
was going to win them back how does it
look it doesn't matter that it stars
Brie lasson in a Perpetual state of just
remembering she left her kid at The Vape
Shop well that it also boasts a talented
diverse curse it's no wonder a movie
called the Marvels didn't do well at the
box office the Marvel name is starting
to mean it's kind of a waste of time got
to say I sometimes miss that giddy
optimism